he did give him hell Indiana Jones a few
times in my life I've seen things
I'm gonna torture with Voodoo
been shot nine times
included once by your father
ah sorry
for this
I just wanted to start by perhaps doing
like a little bit of like a scene
breakdown and the one that I it was hard
to choose which one but Morocco that
whole sequence was so quintessentially
Indie it had the humor it had the action
it had it all so I'll start with you if
you sort of want to maybe talk about
what you recollect from shooting that
scene and how and what makes it so
quintessentially Indie
uh Morocco let's see uh what are we
doing rock you bust out of the hotel oh
yeah yeah okay we're gonna fight over
here oh yeah and the tuck tuck Chase and
all of that stuff right always a tuck
tuck available well we've always gone to
Exotic locales and there's nothing more
exotic in the world than Morocco right
it's a nugget of the past that available
for anybody to go visit and
and we were able to make a movie there
and uh and it brought all kinds of uh of
new visual context to the thing
and it was a great I mean narrow streets
it's perfect for all these kinds of
Chase scenes that we were doing uh so I
loved uh the work we did in Morocco and
we also went to Sicily we worked there
in part of our journey around the world
um these exotic locales bring something
visually interesting new to the audience
and and we've always used them in the
films
um
but you know it's it's it it's a kernel
of the story what takes place in Morocco
is a part of a fabric overall of the
story
and each part of that uh that fabric has
got to hold together uh so uh I'm now
done talking about Morocco the only
things I'd add to it is that I think
that um
I think that the really tricky thing to
to somehow communicate is that every set
piece and kind of sequence in a movie
like this is
an incredibly complex tapestry of things
you're the number of shots stunts
dramatic scenes but what what you're
also trying to do in Indiana Jones film
versus a kind of more conventional
action picture is that character is such
an important part of these movies so I
like to think my personal kind of uh
philosophy is just like you if you're
making a musical the best musicals it's
not like the story stops and they sing
and then the story moves on that through
singing there are more connections made
similarly in a in a kind of action movie
particularly with what Stephen and
Harrison and George developed in the
first Indies the action is a fulfillment
of character not just the most and
greatest and latest display of stunts
and visual effects so that to Do's
Morocco as an example the entire
sequence also becomes an ongoing
argument between Harrison and Phoebe's
character Indie and and Helena Phoebe
while abridges character so that we're
sorting out character stuff while
they're almost getting impaled shot and
run over and that it's this commingling
and kind of tiling of all this stuff on
top of each other that produces some of
the really frantic and wonderful energy
that I think is the Hallmark of these
pictures and I think why you recognize
this feeling particularly Indie yeah he
just nailed it you just nailed the
entire franchise in the series and why
it works and it does feel to use your
term this tapestry I know you don't like
to go into the past too much but this is
probably my last opportunity to ask you
to sort of of reflect on the tapestry
that has been this entire franchise I'm
in a reflective mood good
history away tapas
this film this experience and the whole
and the entire Incredible Journey that
it's been well this is the roundness I
was looking for I was looking for if I
was going to do one more film I wanted
to be character driven as much as any of
them were I want this one to be more
character driven I wanted to know I
wanted to take this character someplace
we had not been before with him
I wanted to see the effect of of the
life that he had lived on him
and we see it in his domestic
arrangements with his with his wife we
see it in the messy New York tenement
Department that he now inhabits
there's nothing poetic about it about it
it's just
put there for you to see and you find
your your friend your the character that
you've come to see
in circumstances where you just say whoa
wait a minute what what's going on here
but I think it's perfect it's a
wonderful dramatic device
so we and we are able then to watch the
new characters in his life
boy him up to the surface again that was
a part of the tapestry
can you reflect on the first four films
I can I can only say that I'm delighted
to be able to make films that families
have shared with their children over and
over and over again I mean there's
four generations for new generations
there uh still I hope interested in the
character interested in the in the movie
experience that they can have with this
character these films are more about
movies and the pleasure of of of
watching a really well made movie then
they are about our archeology
but they're essentially about human
relationships and and and what it means
to be a complex human being
Jesus
[Applause]
I need to introduce myself I'm retiring
well in that case what are we drinking
same for the goddaughter God told me you
found something
on a train during the war a dial that
could change the course of history I
asked Harrison James to start a mini
scene breakdown of the Morocco sequence
I'm going to ask you to continue it as
actors what do you remember about
shooting that scene the logistics of it
because it kind of has everything right
it's got the humor the action the the
roller coaster
I remember we used to shoot it from the
beginning of the shooting and to the end
you know we started shooting what
now go on
we started to shoot it in Morocco yeah
and we finished it in London yes yes
until the last day
you were doing that on the last day
it was very long to shoot I remember it
was
like he took a big part of the shooting
yes and it's funny because we don't
necessarily know exactly what's going to
be left over to do in London the stuff
that we did in Morocco was just totally
immersive because we're yeah we're there
and you can feel the heat in the and the
air and the smells and everything and
it's lucky we did that first because
then you can kind of bring that back but
then we had that little bit that we had
to do on the lot when I crashed the
tuk-tuk and then I wasn't allowed to do
it anymore
yeah yeah I wasn't it he was in it in
the back yeah as it crashed into the
back of the Mercedes all the Nazis in it
I was just like oh my God and then I was
like oh my God his mom's never gonna
forgive me literally his little head
came up and he was like what happened
he's alive
we're driving and I heard cat and we're
still driving and I was like what's
happening right now
I think there's like a moment in the
film from another bit in the film where
like Matt is looking out the back of the
car but that's exactly what I saw when I
was crashing it like
that was a real reaction
oh my gosh that's a great oh my gosh
that's a great story yeah that's
adorable you you actually in that
sequence you reminded me a little bit of
Temple of Doom I don't know did you
watch Temple of Doom of course because
it's like because I think you and kihui
Kwan were the two youngest ever in the
franchise what is it about the trio do
you think that works so much and what
did you think of Keys performance in
that movie did it inspire you and yours
yeah it really inspired me um I used to
watch um Temple of Doom as a kid and I
still watch it now and um yeah his
performance is amazing and um I think
um Teddy and him are kind of similar
because um they both admire an adult who
is like an adventurer I think they're
kind of different anyway because um like
uh Helena is a thief and Teddy's also a
thief and short run is not reality but
um they quite they're quite similar yeah
good energy yeah
Phoebe I actually and I didn't know this
the last time I talked to you that um
you were nervous on the first day and
Harrison like clocked you with his
script or something like this did it
help it really did it was perfect it was
perfect because I was sort of doing that
thing of like oh I feel a bit I was just
in my head too much and I've been
thinking because I've been thinking
about it for so long and then there was
a break because Harrison's shoulder went
I was thinking about it again and
suddenly you're on set and suddenly
there's that moment when they go and
action and all that noise of that year
of the preparation and the like the
training all that kind of stuff and
suddenly it's and go and I was just like
huh
I sort of got to that place so I asked
him after that I was like can you just
like I apologize for having my head was
a bit full and he just emptied it by
going back and then he said you're doing
good kid and that is you know what I
mean
that's all you need you were so cool
common collected in the film I would
never I was like I wrote down like how I
get her I I was like how
your parents you brought them to can oh
you're talking about that that must have
been like hey Mom and Dad we're going to
Camp
they were actually with me um during the
entire shooting so I thought it was like
the continuation of that to bring them
to can with me and they were always with
me and they always support me in in my
acting process this is an amazing family
your family is incredible thank you and
this guy is an absolute genius I don't
know if they told you that he plays the
piano and writes scripts and speaks
multiple languages I mean it's
terrifying
you're terrifying
are you writing Indiana Jones six
I could try to forget me
Hitler made mistakes and with this I
will correct them all
stole it then you stole it and then I
stole it it's called capitalism I
each of you I know you saw Indiana Jones
when you were 17 years old and you
wanted to be him from what I understand
but what was the moment for each of you
where you said
I'm in a freaking Indiana Jones movie
like was there a moment that he came out
of his trailer or something like that
we had the first day on set together the
first day on set yeah truly I mean he
was even there but just looking at the
scale and the scope of this film and it
was an exterior shot and there was New
York and we know it's the beginning of
this wonderful Journey for these
characters
um it just it was really impressed upon
me about how big of a deal uh this was
and it was also just really exciting I
think I was grounded rather quickly
um by by Jim and and my cast mates which
was lovely yeah it's just I mean The
Surreal experience that you know you see
this movie when you're I saw the film
Temple of Doom when I was six my
favorite yeah and that's the movie that
you know brought out adventure and me
wanted to go see other films and and
then on the day you're on set and
there's 300 you know crew members and
you've got to go to this Mark and say
that line or you have to reset the
entire thing it takes 30 minutes
and that's but that's the you know the
thrill of why I'd like to do what I do
it's exciting right before I get to mess
I want to know from the two of you
two viewers I know James shot a lot of
stuff practically so how impractical was
it to have and how many streamers were
flying through the air I feel like it
would have been well it's actually the
confetti on this on the ground that is
slippery and Olivia actually broke his
leg the the first day or something in
that first week or yeah the first day
and he's seven foot twos we had to deal
with that the entire shoot and there's a
motorcycle and there's cars and there's
horses running through this so yeah it's
a lot I was just happy to have one job
anything else because it's so
complicated and wonderful but yeah
for you oh and my Indiana Jones
experience there was something about he
was coming out of his trailer one day
good right mine is a trailer story yeah
we would I was supposed to meet up with
him first time we meet Harrison and and
then we're just going through the scenes
and stuff and he comes out well dressed
because apparently he was having a
custom fitting so he came out as Indiana
Jones so that was the first time I met
him so I also realized that's what I'm
doing now yeah I had a chance to speak
to him a couple months ago and I said to
him when do you know you're back in an
Indiana Jones movie he's like I put on
that I cracked that Whip and I'm ready
to go so everybody keeps asking him
about being de-aged and seeing himself
edhed how did you feel about seeing
yourself de-aged I was crossing my
fingers they would do something because
they dyed my hair pitch black and and
that made me just look like a very old
woman so I was like you better do
something more than that
it is it's a scary thing for us as well
right because now they can do whatever
but used in this manner I think is
fantastic because it's it is Harrison
it's him acting it's his face yeah no
exactly and you feel it you feel when
something's authentic and when it's not
authentic I'm wondering for Ollie
because you put the three really do play
more serious characters
but you are in a movie that has so much
tongue-in-cheek to it and humor so do
you sort of do a knot in a wink with the
sort of performance when you're or do
you play it as a drama or do you have to
tweak it based on the type of film that
it is
I kept my fun off camera yeah I was very
a serious actor while we were rolling
um you know I think I think there's a
little bit of something in there like I
think the dialogue that was happening in
my head was like oh my gosh I can't
believe I have to work with these Nazis
and there's some kind of exasperating
about that it's like kind of like a roll
of the eye yeah um yeah well it's truth
and comedy right you just play it play
it straight and
let everybody else else laughing yeah
that's that's how it works kind of but
we know it's bad we know it's Indiana
Jones right little things and not
everything ends up we had a little thing
going on which we found really funny
that this guy who's from Kentucky this
character he just keeps practicing his
German on my character and my character
oh
we had moments like that yeah I was
trying to get into the club being
desperate the word you know the word
destiny Harrison originally wasn't cast
in this movie he was recast in this
movie yeah the original Ranger's still
alive which is insane
and there there's an element of Destiny
obviously you're great actors but was
there any sort of destiny that
intervened for you to be sitting where
you're sitting right now and getting
this role
in terms of this film yeah I don't know
I'm sure there is somewhere I mean at
one point our faces came before uh James
eyes I don't know how that happened but
there must be some tests in you there
yeah
I I met it I met Jim uh for lunch and uh
we rehearsed some scenes a couple days
after that and this was
before we did the film Logan with him
and um
I wouldn't have done this film without
Jim there's there's no way if any other
director would have been doing this I
would said that's that's a bad idea
Harrison said in the Press
the Press so much
very emotional what was your reaction to
that moment
I mean he's worked a lot and he's saying
this about the three of you
I mean I was really touching was he
drinking
[Laughter]
um no really touching and I think um
because we all went into it knowing
again what this means in the gravity of
this of ending this franchise that we
wanted to give it our all every take and
we wanted to to stay present and I think
we're also reflecting his work ethic and
what he brought to set every day yeah
now you're saying there's almost like a
like once you're like you can't let the
whole other films go down because if
this one goes bad feeling of just you
gotta step up and make this happen is
there a quintessential Indiana Jones
scene mean from any of the filmography
you can even choose a scene that you're
in that is now your favorite well I like
the Callback oh can you talk the whip
the gun in the whip
when he had the Whip and everyone else
together
for me it's got to be the first sequence
of the first film that entirety of in
there the rolling Boulder coming after
him coming out seeing the guy who
betrayed him and then realizing there's
a hundred and fifty thousand people
after him he's just an amazing start
over field
I think eating the the monkey brains
that's just
still sticks with me